hi i'm alex and this is my recipe for
banana bread on a stick
so i know this recipe is a little weird
but bear with me here the elements are
all pretty classic banana bread is one
of my all-time favorite foods not even
desserts like foods
so it's one of my favorite things to
recreate for tasty videos i'm not even
quite sure how this idea originally came
to me i just remember like looking at a
banana and being like oh my god kind of
looks like a corn dog
no like one
and then i had the next idea that you
could replace the cornbread crust with
banana bread and voila you got banana
bread on a stick now originally i was
like what do i call this banana dog
banana corn dog but i just settled on
banana bread on a stick because
i don't know banana corn dog kind of
sounds weird
so for this recipe i knew it was super
important to not only nail the flavor
but to make sure i nailed the shape and
look of a corn dog i wanted it to look
exactly the same but just a dessert
version so in order to get that straight
edge on the banana to look like a hot
dog i cut off the ends put a stick in
the middle and then save the ends to put
into the banana bread that i was gonna
make for the batter coating also it's a
great way to not waste any food although
you could have just eaten them
so there are a few tricky variables to
this recipe i have to make sure the
bananas would stay on the sticks
especially while dipping and frying
because bananas are a little more
fragile than like a hot dog would be so
i decided to freeze the bananas
beforehand
now make sure you work quickly because
the bananas will thaw and then you'll
have
a mess
so i know frying bananas sounds a little
weird but you're really just frying
these to cook the banana bread all the
way through and then also get that nice
golden brown coating that every corn dog
should have getting the temperature and
the timing right on frying was a little
bit tricky because in some batches i
didn't cook the banana bread quite all
the way through and in other batches i
cooked it far too much and the banana
ended up mushy in the center so you're
really going for that perfect
temperature and time to cook the banana
bread just through so i know this recipe
seems a little tricky but i promise it's
simple and trust me it's a crowd pleaser
so no corn dog is complete without
ketchup and mustard and no banana dog is
complete without chocolate and caramel
so i added both options for dipping
sauces i mean but you could really dip
it in anything you want i don't know you
could dip it in ketchup or mustard
be kind of gross but
i'm still so proud of this video it was
a crazy idea
but it came out exactly how i pictured
it in my weird crazy mind riya even
tried these and she was a fan and you
know they don't call her the dessert's
not for nothing
seeing something that you've created
from start to finish being received well
by our audience is one of the most
gratifying feelings i know it's just
banana bread on a stick but it brought
happiness to people's lives and i'm
proud of it i felt like i was able to
bring happiness on a stick
all right there okay
awesome
[Music]
[Music]
you